au large de l'île maurice dans l'océan
indien
le temps pressait pour pomper des
hydrocarbures restant à l'intérieur de
la cale du mbiwa cachot échoué depuis le
25 juillet sur un récif le navire
japonais risquent de se scinder en deux
il transportait près de 4000 tonnes
d'hydrocarbures soit l'équivalent de
cinq piscines olympiques
au total le car aurait été déversé dans
la mer a indiqué le premier ministre de
l'île maurice du gaz qui guette faux
amis le drame a des conséquences
majeures sur la vie des mauriciens les
la bride des récifs coralliens de
renommée mondiale et le tourisme reste
un enjeu économique important c'est
notre but et synthes est notre richesse
et notre maison c'est notre patrimoine
c'est gras c'est grâce à ça que beaucoup
de mauriciens et vive
j'ai vu des gens qui venaient me morice
de toutes les villes qui avaient
vraiment y avait beaucoup de coller
depuis l'incident des équipes
d'intervention des nations unies et du
japon ont été dépêchés sur les lieux
les mauriciens ont tout de même voulu
mettre la main à la pâte pour freiner la
nappe de pétrole mardi les mises en
garde du gouvernement
plusieurs actifs jour et nuit à la
construction de boudins flottants
confectionné à l'aide de feuilles de
canne à sucre de bouteilles en plastique
et de cheveux ce n'est pas le premier
accident dans lequel la compagnie en
charge nvwa cascio est impliqué en 2006
le pétrolier bright artemis qu'elle
exploite et a été endommagée provoquant
le déversement de 4500 tonnes de pétrole
brut dans l'océan indien
ici gabriel proulx radio canada montréal